I if if my math is right you're 1995
until 2002 seven years and the Beatles
were actually together for exactly seven
years that's crazy right and I would
have a tough time believing that the
Beatles during their seven years sold 70
million albums back in the time like
that there yeah so like I think that
that means that like per the numbers
objectively you guys were far bigger
than the Beatles kind of sort of I'll
never forget uh stepen Tyler said this
to me we were at a concert one time this
is after ins you know we split and do
our own thing I went to go see his
concert goes hey man when you guys
getting back together again I don't know
I'm going to ask Justin he was on tour
whatever he's like dude he goes I'm not
kidding he goes the last time I saw the
girl scream like that when I saw your
show was when I went and saw The Beatles
in 63 or something like that he saw the
con he goes I've never heard it that
loud before like that and I never
thought it or took it in perspective
like that I really didn't we like o
we're bigger than the Beatles but it's
interesting enough that's only it's not
a very big span seven years is kind of
short and it's amazing how much and the
longevity of us or just even the group
even now just because it just I don't
know I guess boy bands come back and go
you know same thing with music but now
people are like oh we want to do boy
band stuff and 90s music now and like
[__] I'll hire my ass I'll do it right
the beos aren't considered a boy band
sorry
they're but are they a boy band is that
a certain genre day I mean that's the
thing they always had the the the
argument you know you even say Boys to
Men were you were boy band no they were
a vocal group that's the same thing with
us but however we do all actually
somewhat play instruments and this
actually one of our shows we played the
song That Thing You Do from that movie
The Tom H movie but it's funny because
no one ever saw that we yeah thank you
so we we did that and everybody played
instruments people like oh [__] you
actually play I was like yeah but we
more vocal group than anything else and
Justin JC did a lot of writing yeah I
mean a boy band means like a group of
dudes
that just like have millions of chicks
like just crunched at the crotch no but
I'm saying like cuz cuz one of the stats
some you want them to and some you
don't but it said it said uh you guys
were the highest grossing boy band but
that's not
considering the
Beatles the The Beatles were a group of
dudes who appealed to chicks and as such
the boy band I got you yeah it's weird
they have people always say yeah boy
band vocal group or no we're we're a
group and they I don't know I I think
all it's man banned now when you get
older what like what what are you going
to really say [__] when you have that
such huge success at a young age like
that and you're raking in all this cash
like you buy stupid [__] yeah do you
just go [__] crazy like well like do
you have people managing your money do
you say I'm I'm over 18 I'm going to do
what I want you know just like anything
I think when people come into money that
fast that have never been into money
like that my family's never come to
money that so my family doesn't know
much about investing I was a middle
class family from Brook Brooklyn when
you got money you got a paycheck you
[__] blew it you went you took your
girl out you did this or your family and
the half the time you ow me 100 bucks in
your account to go okay not going to pay
my bills so when I had that money it was
just numbers in a bank account yeah I
mean I knew it of course but I'm like
you know I'm 19 years old going you know
Dad I'm thinking about buying a house
I'm think about buying a car and my dad
looks at me and I go what kind of car
you think I should get like I really
don't know how much you know he goes
dude my dad goes you can buy whatever
[__] car you want right now you can
you honestly can I said really so I
remember look slowly I started buying
purchases and stuff that but then I
bought stuff where I thought you know
again 19 years old I could buy my own
house I want a couch that had every
cushion was different [__] colors
that was custom made I had a Star Wars
room of theater that liter had bought
the house was 250,000 I bought the house
and the theater cost me about 400,000
the theater cost more than the [__]
house but it was like I put my hand on
the handprint and hydraulically slid
open it closed and it had Han Solo in
the Carbonite the Frozen carite I had
the de star with the freaking projector
I had a [__] M it was crazy it was
the stupidest [__] but it was worth more
than but the coolest [__] but after a
while you start buying [__] and the same
way you said one of my my first account
was like yeah you're going to be good
your family family is going to be good
this this this but doesn't really
explain everything taxes of just
everything back to the back to the Star
Wars theater yeah so you were gay
yes I have a start of lightsaber on my
face
100% uh I think we were all gay once we
watch of course i k um but
now I uh watched the the Lou Pearlman
documentary like famously like Lou
Pearlman signed the Backstreet Boys then
he signed in sync and like he worked
with a lot yeah he he was a smart
businessman for himself is what I like
to call him right um and and so like
this whole back and forth between the
back she boys and in sync and he was
just like he was the middle man just
laughing though cuz he what he would do
is he was literally almost push us
against each other put in a friendly way
going oh those guys are doing this G you
should do that oh they're working out
they look better you should work out
more you know so it was that kind of
thing and then funny they always kept us
apart not knowing why and there was a
lot of conversations that when we
finally started talking to each other
like oh wait a minute so l perlman's a
six member with you guys you two so he's
splitting you guys six ways and us six
ways but wait a minute he's also a
manager so he's getting a management fee
but he's also telling us that he can
make sure to take care of the lawyers
cuz he has his lawyers but want to make
sure that since he's a six member he's
going to secure his ass and our ass so
he was double triple and fipple in
everything wow then he started a Ponzi
scheme he started telling people you
know I got Britney Spears which he did
at one point like he's I got Brittney I
got uh Backstreet I got in sync invest
in my company transcon we'll have you go
invest in this thing it's going to be
great blah blah blah these people are
like old
retirees literally giving their money
life savings and they would say what are
we doing oh it's great uh stock is going
up let me show you the print outs get
printouts then when they try to collect
money they couldn't get a hold of
anybody and it literally was a pond
schem he stole like billions of dollars
[__] and just ran and you're like why
would you do that when you made a
legitimate business though he
legitimately started making his own real
[__] business and was really making
money and then he got too damn greedy
which is crazy to me yeah and and and
like by structuring it so that he was a
member of the band and the management
fee and controlling lawyers on top of
that like he didn't pay you what you
were rightfully entitled to is that
right no and then they were all well
everything that we were doing was uh
recuperable that was the fun part too we
thought every time he was taking out to
taking us out to dinner I'll take you
guys to dinner and we'll go here Peter
Luger is going hey and then all of a
sudden the bill everything's all up
there one time the funniest [__]
thing and I remember that's what I was
like wait a minute something's really
[__] up we were I remember we were
shooting the Tearing Up My Heart video
and we were in Miami and me and Justin's
birthday was around this time around
January he's like I'll buy you buy a
gift like oh cool buy like his Armani
jacket that I saw I was like I [__]
love that that's great oh 250 bucks man
for me 17 years old [__] expand of
[__] was on the [__] recoupable thing
so anything I bought he bought me a
birthday gift but I was paying for it
because it was on my recoupable bill
Jesus Christ so I was like all right now
there's something [__] wrong here and
even even the record company is like I
don't know what's going on we're giving
you millions of dollars but it's not
going to you it's being split but I'm
I'm hearing getting checks for like 20
grand 30 grand that's it so yeah sounds
like we got [__] sounds like the way
that uh I've heard YouTubers describe
Dan Bilzerian um managing
ignite exactly yeah it's just it's it's
just mindboggling I think when things
get to a certain degree or money starts
really coming and and you see a lot of
artists like that I think even Billy
Joel's manager you know kind of [__]
them over M so much definitely it's
crazy though you just can't there you go
when it comes in that fast and that
quick you can't really or try to
establish you really have to have a
handle on it or know the business and
again that's why we're talking about
spending money I never had that business
savvy I invest or where do I need to
[__] put my money in [__] and now
thank the Lord I do do you like shopping
on Amazon I do and good news is sto's
butt wipes for your butthole are
available on Amazon and if you want a
real bundle of a deal you can get sto's
hot sauce for your butthole plus steo
butthole destroyer and steo butt wipes
for your butthole it's the butthole
bundle available on Amazon right
now yeah dude